wahrscheinlich habe ich jetzt eine
bürste was glaubt willkommen bei neuen
video
ja ich habe mir für heute natürlich mal
wieder was ganz spezielles einfallen
lassen ich denke mir nämlich bei mädchen
immer so die haben wirklich für jede
kleinigkeit irgendwelche produkte die
man irgendwo kaufen kann und ich
verstehe von diesen ganzen produkten so
allerhöchstens zwei prozent und ja ich
habe mir heute eine ganz nette
assistentin geholt wo ich auch mal denke
was hast du da in deiner tasche drin was
was macht man damit
und ich versuche immer ein paar produkte
davon halt den sinn davon zu erraten
meine nette hübsche assistentin hat sich
ein paar sehr coole sachen rausgesucht
vielleicht auch das eine oder andere
perversen sex spielt nicht was also das
sind jetzt ein paar lustige produkte
dabei glaube ich und ich würde sagen wir
fangen an mit produktnummer 1 okay okay
also leute produkte heißt ist ein pinsel
da könnte man also ich könnte den jetzt
für nix benutzen außer einer nadel zu
bauen
ich hab voll so pollen meisten die
kommen jetzt wieder alle raus also
keinen plan was das ist alter vielleicht
kann man damit die wimpern sauber machen
wir lassen dass das ist ein weiß ich
nicht also ich würde sagen es für um die
wimpern zu säubern
stimmt das also macht man die wimpern
damit sauber also würde also ich würd
damit auf jeden fall in der nase bohren
ok nächste utensil das ist wenn man hier
zum beispiel unter die augen kann man
sich dann so einen schatten malen oder
gibt man einen pinsel einmal
nein ich traurig bin es nicht schön so
leute die machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt das ist zeigt man glaub ich mal
haben das ist dieses nette tonne teil
hier sieht aus wie ein keine ahnung
vorjahr beauty was hat das bitte mit
beauty zu tun was ist daran beauty was
was soll man damit anfangen das beauty
ist machst bist du auch 1 voll geil
alter kummer
das habe ich neue bekommen weil gut
verzichten
da steht irgendwas vom beauty drauf aber
das ist eigentlich ein fall wenn er das
gut verwechselt weißt du ja so dass wir
jetzt die sache die mir dazu einfallen
würde ansonsten vielleicht können sich
frauen die stark behaart sind damit ihre
ihre links punkt rausziehen du hast auch
so was sollte ich habe keine ahnung
gib mir deine bürste war wie gut alter
wo ich mich regt das immer so aufregen
wenn irgendein mädchen was hier ist so
irgendeine so mit meiner bürste sich
ihre haare bürstet und dann ist einfach
die ganze wirst du voll mit
irgendwelchen hahn und die kriege ich da
nicht raus deswegen wollte ich mir zum
teil voll geil das ja auch dumm dann
hast die haare hier raus geholt aber die
sind hier drin
dann braucht man jetzt wahrscheinlich
noch ein teil
was hier für die haare raus macht
wahrscheinlich hierzu eine bürste
gerückt okay wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten produkt
das erinnert mich ein bisschen an diese
so spielparks wieder wo man als kind
immer drin war dann gab es mal so
schaumstoff sache zu recht warum warum
gibt es so was und das soll jetzt
irgendwas mit in der verbindung zu zu
mädchen beauty lifestyle mich mit mäßig
sein oder wie alt ich habe einfach drauf
gebissen als ja stahl drin
jetzt habe ich den sinn erkannt das ist
nur ein schaumstoff umrandung damit das
produkt drin damit das gut erhalten
bleibt also wenn man dieses produkt sich
kauft muss man es vielleicht ist das
eine haarspange ganz ehrlich was soll
man sonst hier mitmachen
sag mal was macht man damit etwas kann
man lieben ja ach und entwickelt man die
haare darum und dann fühlt man was und
sonnenkraft man kriegt man locken
okay leute das hier sind papillons india
piloten heißen die super sache kann ich
jedem empfehlen kauft euch die unter
meinem linklink in der beschreibung okay
gibt man das nächste produkt das auch
übrigens gleichzeitig unser letztes
produkte haben wir einen roten ich würde
jetzt sagen das ist ein kampf aber dafür
sind deutlich diese sachen so vielleicht
meine frau guckt mal leute da sind so
ganz kleine noppen dran vielleicht wenn
du frau wirklich nur eine glatze
sicherheit schneiden lassen
weißt du und 1 grad wieder gekommen um
die hörer zu können vielleicht kann man
sich da wird auch marschieren oder
vielleicht kann man sich damit
abschminken also wenn man vielleicht
sich normal ich doch das geht immer wenn
man sich normale schminke drauf tut dann
macht man vielleicht hier abschminken
dran und schminkt sich dann so ab dass
das denn
oder fühlt sich gut an
da kann ich ja gar nicht aufhören es
entspannend und wenn man sich nicht
eincremen
das tut ja wir haben wir die verpackung
ebeling professional gesichts peeling
massage pat war das ist einfach null
massage diesem produkt gebe ich ganz
klar von 10 punkten gar kein ja heute
das war's mit dem video das euch
gefallen hat dann lasst auf jeden fall
jetzt mal daumen nach oben da wenn ihr
wollt dass ich noch weitere beauty
produkte von euch frauen oder mädchen
test warum schüttelt den kopf
natürlich finden wir noch was
mal in die kommentare was ich testen
soll du liest das dann durch und besorgt
dass und also wenn du das nicht hast
dann besorgt du das und dann teste ich
dass es nicht nur okay okay schreibt in
die kommentare
was soll ich noch testen ja und wenn ihr
dann halte ich die zweite folge sehen
sollte er lasse jetzt mal kräftig die
daumen nach oben da dann sehe ich auch
dass er die sehen wollt und snapshot uns
damals eingeblendet könnt ihr gerne
folge oben links geht weiter mit meinem
letzten video aber nicht vergessen und
hat drei leute mit v bei alex v wie
macht sinn